[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
jetzt im sommer finde ich immer ganz
schön wenn man leichte systems machen
kann
und jetzt habe ich mir gedacht ich mach
ein schickes tiramisu was auch
gleichzeitig sehr leicht ist
normalerweise mache ich tiramisu immer
ganz gerne mit eiern und mit mascarpone
und ist natürlich dann vor sehr lecker
aber natürlich auch ziemlich schwer
und heute habe ich eine fruchtige
leichte alternative mit etwas quark und
joghurt
ich werde das ganze dann später in
kleinen gläsern anrichten
so kann man zum beispiel auch mit den
garten oder mit auf die terrasse nehmen
und hat wirklich auch ein super bisher
für unterwegs
ich zeige euch mal kurz die zutaten
dafür brauche ich löffelbiskuits die
können jetzt gekauft oder auch selbst
gemacht seien 250 gramm früchte die sind
tiefgefroren 200 gramm quark 150 gramm
joghurt 35 gramm puderzucker etwas
vanille extrakt eine zitrone die
unbehandelt ist hier habe ich
flüssigkeit und zwar insgesamt 80
milliliter habe ich jetzt einen espresso
und 50 milliliter geschafft und ich wäre
das ganze und küchenmaschine zubereiten
es gibt wirklich total schnell und
einfach jetzt ruhig erst einmal die
creme zusammen und nehmen dafür den
quark und dann auch den joghurt habe ich
jetzt ein naturjoghurt mit 35 prozent
fettanteil dann kommt der puderzucker
noch mit rein und da könnt ihr natürlich
auch nach belieben etwas weniger nehmen
also ich nehme lieber etwas puderzucker
stadt zum beispiel einen
zuckeraustauschstoff das wird natürlich
auch gehen aber ich bin dann eher der
meinung man sollte einfach super oder
gar kein zu können
dann kommt jetzt ein bisschen meinl
extrakten sein
du erzählst ganz fleißig mit und auch
der abrieb der zitrone die sollte auf
jeden fall umgespritzt sein so dass man
die schale eben mit verzehren kann
[Musik]
jetzt versuche ich alles mit einem
schneebesen dann wird es nämlich schön
glatt
[Musik]
nämlich die beiden flüssigkeiten
vermischt sie in einem tiefen teller
ihr könnt jetzt natürlich auch auf den
espresso verzichten weil gerne espresso
markt gibt es mit dazu ansonsten könnt
ihr auch nur kirschsaft oder auch in
anderen saft benutzen
krems die löffel bizkit und taucht jeder
ein von beiden seiten
und hier habe ich jetzt auch schon meine
gläser dessen zu einmachgläser ihr könnt
natürlich auch ganz normale trinkgläser
zum beispiel benutzen
und da die löffel bizkit reinsetzen
nehme ich jetzt immer einen pro glas
[Musik]
die restliche flüssigkeit gebe ich dann
einfach noch mit drauf
[Musik]
jetzt verteidigt darüber die früchte und
die etwas größere ställe die erdbeeren
zum beispiel habe ich ein bisschen klein
geschnitten und kanada wo frische
früchte nehmen wie genau man kann auch
frische früchte nehmen alles was man da
hat so hat man halt direkt ganz kalt
also das finde ich auch mal ganz
praktisch aber alles was der kühlschrank
hergibt
wie lange das aufbewahren eine frist
gewesen
das kann man dann eigentlich zwei tage
ungefähr aufbewahren sollte es aber dann
wirklich am zweiten tag auf jeden fall
essen
[Musik]
jetzt drücke ich die früchte so ein
bisschen fest weil dadurch dass jetzt
auch gefroren sind wollen wir später
noch ein bisschen zusammen beim
anschauen und das später einfach das
tiramisu nicht so ganz in sich
zusammensackt bei frischen früchten
würde ich das aber genauso machen also
gerade ein bisschen drücken damit gleich
platz für die creme ist
[Musik]
die creme für dich jetzt in einen
spritzbeutel denn damit kann ich jetzt
ein bisschen sauberer arbeiten
ihr könnt aber auch zum beispiel einen
gefrierbeutel nehmen oder das ganze auch
einfach mit löffeln einfüllen
ich persönlich ja dann verschwinden
immer so ein bisschen den rand deswegen
mache ich lieber mit einem spritzbeutel
mit einem gefrierbeutel jetzt nach vorne
eine spitze abschneiden und dann fühle
ich jetzt die creme hier auf
[Musik]
also jetzt sind im prinzip schon fertig
die müssen jetzt natürlich noch in den
kühlschrank
man können sie jetzt natürlich auch
direkt verzehren aber ich finde es immer
ganz schön wenn sie durch sehen
das heißt jetzt fertig habt könnt ihr es
hier so jetzt verschließen und dann zum
beispiel mit zu einer grillfeier nehmen
noch einmal einen kühlschrank stellen
und daneben wenn es dass das herausholen
kurz vor dem vertrag geben wir natürlich
gleich noch cacau 58 drauf denn es kommt
ja beim echten klar wieso auch mit drei
euro pro lizenz zum beispiel
aber ich gebe es jetzt erst mal in den
kühlschrank für mindestens zwei stunden
dann schmeckt nämlich richtig lecker und
danach direkt probieren im kühlschrank
auf jetzt auch darum kindergartens darf
dem ura direkt probieren aber du
möchtest uns noch was zeigen was ist das
und hätte ihn gemacht papa auch fast
mein vogel schon mal gesehen
die fünf mädchen pferd ist genau jetzt
darfst du da noch kakaopulver
drüberstreuen dann nehme ich immer bei
kakao also ungelöst
super es reicht dann darfst du das
direkt probieren
so will man einst mal alle nach so
einfach ganz schützenhilfe von oben nach
ganz unten also im kern schichtwasser
ganz unten die löffel ihr okay alles
mitgenommen wie und er hat mit einem
löffel das komplette dorf zerstört
je nachdem was früher ihr nehmt wenn
jetzt nur dass er natürlich etwas süßes
aber ich habe zu viele johannisbeeren
auch mit drin deswegen steuerlich ist
gut richtig und perfekt für den garten
und für perfekt richtig ich mal gesagt
keine zinsen besonders säuerlicher
perfekt genau und wie gesagt ist auch
wirklich sehr wenig zucker drin aber
wenn ihr möchtet können ja natürlich
auch noch gerne etwas mehr nehmen das
machen wir gleich fürs foto k alles klar
und ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel
spaß beim nachmachen dieses fünf minuten
tiramisu und wenn ihr es macht dann
könnt ihr mir gerne auf facebook oder
instagram und fotos schicken und mich
drauf verlinken
also bis anhin und eine musik genau
[Musik]